in many ways we have become a nation of
should i say excuses
we say this person cannot do such and
such because
and you fill in the blank excuses
[Music]
it's a cold winter night and i'm still
here living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the awareness that you
need about the gun violence on the south
side of chicago but also to raise as
much money as we possibly can on this
block called o block to build a
community center the reason why it's
called o block is because it's named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed the gangs picked up the
o in his name and started calling it o
block we decided we're going to keep the
o but we're going to change it to
opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every single day to bring
into you rooftop revelations
where i share with you my thoughts my
viewpoints and opinions
on things that are happening around
chicago but even around our country
in an earlier rooftop revelation i spoke
about the need to have school choice and
i spoke about an elementary school that
it sits only two blocks away from where
i sit
only six percent of the kids at the
school are proficient in reading
only four percent of the kids are
proficient in math
this is simply outrageous and
mind-boggling
well i believe that school choice is the
key to free up our kids to attend better
schools of their choice in the city
i cannot ignore the issue
of parents
in many ways we have become a nation of
should i say excuses
we say this person cannot do such and
such because
and you fill in the blank excuses
now i'm not saying this to be mean or
judgmental i'm talking from the world of
reality
sometimes excuses simply cannot be used
to explain failure away
especially when it comes to an innocent
child
that child is an innocent child that
child knows nothing about why the world
they live in is the way that it is
that child depends on the parent and no
excuses
should be allowed to undermine that
several weeks ago i had a woman on the
rooftop
revelations who lost her husband to a
brutal murder by a gang
she had five children she had a job she
was going to school too
she raised all five girls because she
never allowed herself to fall back on
excuses
i speak of excuses because there is
simply no reason why parents should
allow their kids to go into a failing
school
that has such low proficiency numbers
why aren't the parents boycotting why
aren't they demanding accountability
well i hate to say it but perhaps there
is no accountability at the school
because there's no accountability in the
home
i've seen a lot of these families
and i've seen how they live
i've seen them not put in the work into
the kids i've tried to counsel them and
into doing better show them a way that
is better
sometimes i i get through but it's
difficult
some of the parents also went to these
very same failing schools so they are
undereducated themselves
even the generation and the generation
before them
this cycle is brutal this cycle is
vicious
my family came out of slavery and even
they came out of better conditions than
some of these homes
i say all of this out of empathy not
excuses
i'm done with excuses
all it does is enable the cycle to
continue
we and what i mean by we is the parents
have to put the brakes on the vicious
cycle we have to stop the excuses we
have to go to the school and demand
accountability we have to educate our
kids in our own homes before and after
school
education must be number one
when someone says i can or gives an
excuse we must tell them they have no
choice
but to be better
the very life of the child depends on
that think about it if we make these
chances take charge of our own
fates the children will grow up seeing
the changes we are making the child will
come to know that as part of their world
they can't make excuses they will come
to know aspiration they will know the
feeling of what they have achieved and
the tests they have passed they will
know the joy of graduating they'll know
the feeling of buying their own home of
having a successful family they will
know that opportunity means what it
means and uplifting them what it can be
isn't that a far better way than the
world of excuses and poverty
that they know now
it begins with the parents
it doesn't matter if it's only a father
or a mother or a grandparent it begins
with the family
once you decide to take charge
the doors of the world were open
i know this
because that was part of
my life
even now
my mother who is battling cancer
she calls me every day
and she ends the conversation
the same way i've heard her for many
many many many years as a kid
corey
no excuses
you